this video is brought to you by henson
shaving tesla has fascinated the world
with its cool and fast electric cars now
it wants to disrupt a related industry
insurance tesla has been quietly selling
insurance for the last couple of years
but it won't be quiet for much longer
ceo elon musk believes insurance will
one day account for a third of tesla's
business it will be much more compelling
than anything else out there it's going
to cost less and be better so why would
you tesla started selling personal car
insurance in california in 2019 and
claims drivers can trim their insurance
costs by as much as 20 or 30 percent
data compiled by the personal financial
website value penguin shows tesla
insurance is not the cheapest in
california but it is amongst the least
expensive it is said to be the least
costly plan in texas where tesla has a
lot going on a new gig factory is being
built near austin and musk permanently
moved to the lone star state to be
closer to spacex's rocket facility for
starship state regulators there have
reportedly approved the rates and
policies for tesla insurance which
according to data compiled by value
penguin is
1795 on average individual rates do
differ greatly depending on your driving
record age how much coverage you choose
and the tesla you buy the model y
mid-size suv is the least expensive to
ensure and if you take the model s rates
could be more expensive for the plaid
which goes zero to 100 in 2.1 seconds
compared with the long range version's
3.2 seconds
so why can't tesla afford to lower
insurance rates it says it will do away
with fees taken by traditional insurance
carriers an example of fees is
commissions paid to insurance brokers
and more importantly tesla argues no one
knows more about a tesla than tesla
while other insurance companies set
their insurance rates based on their own
risk assessments which could be inflated
because the technology is so new tesla
believes only it knows the cars well
enough to determine fare rates the
insane amount of data collected from its
cars tracks how fast you drive the
number of times the lane departure
warning is triggered whether you're in
ludicrous mode or the even faster plaid
mode although tesla says it does share
driving data with other insurers the
belief is that it uniquely understands
its vehicles technology safety and
repair costs for the moment tesla says
it doesn't actually use your personal
driving data to determine your rate but
that will most certainly change musk has
already alluded to this they want to buy
tails insurance that they have to agree
to not drive the car in a crazy way or
they can but then there's insurance
rates higher toyota has already been
testing this out it partnered with
insurance company progressive to start
tracking driving behaviors in toyotas
with connected technology to potentially
offer discounts there's a lot of room
for discounting when it comes to
electric vehicles
the typical insurance company has been
found to price evs at 23 more than a
gas-powered equivalent primarily due to
the expensive cost of repairing them a
few years ago a writer for cleantechnica
described clipping a parking sign in his
model 3 and the repair bill was nearly a
whopping seven thousand dollars because
of the technology in the car the sensors
needed to be recalibrated and the
battery connector is disconnected tesla
thinks it has an advantage here as well
the company says its own service centers
can work four times faster than
conventional ones the number of tesla
repair centers has been rapidly
expanding and the goal is to reportedly
open up one new shop every week in 2021
but ultimately tesla wants to make its
vehicles so reliable that you won't
really need to visit a service center
tesla believes its self-driving software
called full self-driving or fsd will
make its cars safer and less prone to
accidents this is the software that
tesla hopes will take its cars from
level 2 autonomy in which the driver has
to be prepared to take the wheel all the
way up to level 5 in which the driver
doesn't have to pay any attention at all
tesla will even offer insurance
discounts for those using their driver
assistance systems if and when teslas
are able to fully drive themselves it
doesn't mean accidents won't happen
technology can fail or humans can fail
to use it properly so how on earth will
other insurance companies assess the
risk it will be easier over time as more
data comes in that will better inform
companies about pricing risk in line
with reality but they may have a hard
time catching up to tesla which is now
seeking to offer coverage in texas
illinois and washington the goal is
nationwide coverage and one day perhaps
global it's clear that tesla wants to
offer a complete package to the consumer
apple has done this successfully by
creating an ecosystem where its devices
are designed to work seamlessly with one
another which entices you to buy them
all tesla is also trying to build its
own ecosystem in which your house has a
tesla solar roof that generates energy
that can be stored in a tesla powerwall
which can power your home at night or
during an outage the powerwall can also
charge your tesla and then you can
purchase autopilot in full self-driving
software for your car and your car is
conveniently covered by tesla insurance
but not everyone is a fan of the
insurance plan berkshire hathaway ceo
warren buffett said bluntly at an annual
shareholders meeting that the success of
the auto companies getting into the
insurance business is probably as likely
as the success of the insurance
companies getting into the auto business
buffett became one of the wealthiest
people on earth by investing in
insurance companies despite his
skepticism musk has proven his debtors
wrong time and time again and he
believes tesla insurance will be
stunningly successful insurance could
very well be on a 30-40 percent of the
value of the car business frankly if
tesla reaches its goal of producing 20
million cars a year by 2030 and you
multiply that by 1 795
in annual insurance premiums that brings
in 36 billion a year that's 36 billion
year after year after year and owners of
a robo taxi the planned ride sharing
network would likely pay higher premiums
due to the many more hours the vehicles
are on the road in the way that tesla
has been revolutionizing the car
industry musk is betting it can do the
same to the car insurance business
there's also another company
revolutionizing an industry the shaving
industry when henson shaving read shed
about trying their razor and possibly
sponsoring the video i didn't actually
know a lot about them i've now learned
that they build their razors with the
help of their family-owned canadian
aerospace manufacturer that built parts
for the mars rover to ensure that their
razor meets extremely tight tolerances
that precision really gives a smoother
shave this razor has very little blade
exposure less than 30 microns and it's
easy to use there's no learning period
like with other safety razors because
the shaving angle is built into the head
design now that i've tried out a henson
i won't be using disposable razors
anymore although this razor costs more
than disposable ones you make your money
back because it lasts a lifetime and get
this the cost of a blade is only 10
cents if you change your blade every
week then you'll pay just five dollars
for an entire year's supply the razor
comes in eight colors and ships all
around the world if you like to try out
a henson razor or gift one to your
family or a friend then you can use the
link in my description thanks so much
for watching for news think i'm cindy
palm
[Music]